hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich bin hier
zusammen mit meinem pixel das heutige
video ist man hier ein google play video
ihr kennt es ja ich mal ein paar videos
für den google places mit dem google
bläst mit apps aus dem google places und
heute habe ich mir was besonderes
überlegt und zwar wenn ich mit der kugel
daydream wie a spiele ausprobiert also
spiele in der virtuellen realität und da
nicht irgendwie irgendwelche alle spiele
die ich heute spiele drehen sich um höhe
das heißt ich habe zu meinen bungee
jumping dann habe ich einen wingsuit
spiel und ein parcours spielt wer
schonmal dpa anwendung ausgetestet dann
weisst dass es total echtes also wenn
man kein plan wirklich auf einem gebäude
steht und runter geguckt wird und fangen
schon so die die füße zu zittern an und
genau darum geht es um diesen effekt und
ich würde sagen die legen einfach direkt
los was als erstes bankintern pink war
die doping ist schon sagte ich mache mit
links hut da musst du so richtig so dich
rum steuern und was noch habe ich nehme
als lässt als erste mal dieses spiele
highlights wie awo man einfach nur nur
ein parcours machen mussten dass auf den
dächern startet dr
und es geht okay okay ich glaube schon
irgendwie rum was man kopf nach links
drehen und weiter zu springen
das ist richtig
okay man will aber gesteuert jetzt geht
es hier wo nach oben schauen ist roger
rütter
das ist schon mal ein spray sie okay wer
weiß das schon
das kannst du schon gewesen sein 3
congratulations york city cross the area
ich gehe mal wieder ins hauptmenü zurück
public sohn okay da werde ich nicht mehr
geführt dass test die jetzt noch mal
kurz fuhr
okay und ich bin direkt runter gefallen
wie sieht das eigentlich aus wenn man es
nicht sehen kann komisch oder
wir sind also genau von vorne
okay so das ist übertrieben schnell was
wird hier gilt auch hier no flop no drop
ok
das ist doch verrückt das geht so weit
runter um ein coach ok go getan hier
vorne
ich glaube die außer über irgendwelche
balken so in so einer halbierten welt
und das ist übertrieben hoch genutzt
haben ausprobiert stimmt
bei mir steht zum raum und wo ich würde
ja darüber sagt aber ich habe keine
ahnung was bei die politiker okay was
siehst du das schreibt mal gerade stand
ich schon bei konstant alles gewackelt
aber klar ich habe es jetzt geschafft ja
ich habe es geschafft und spannt also
ich sehe ja nicht was du siehst führt
aber ich glaube weil die brille aufhat
ist entspannt mit der brille es ist echt
gut des br muss ich sagen als nächstes
mache ich bungee jumping ich habe es die
app gestartet
das spiel beginnt oha das direkt neben
mir das nun richtig richtig verschlossen
richtig schwarzarbeit to the break das
soll die brücke sein
das ist einfach so ein holz ding der
später unter wasser aber ich laufe
gerade and lernen also dass wir alles
unfassbar gut ich habe schon fertig die
alten ausprobiert und man hat echt also
ist sehr sehr gut
jumping fließt des fahrers erkennt gut
da ich wie du es auf injury major wird
okay also ich muss weit raus springen
damit ich mich nicht verletze
little big point der drei ist der
checkpoint das ist halt richtig hoch
mein gott was ist dann fleck auf dem
sofa
es ist so hoch es ist so wie hoch
schätzen was ist das was denkst du jung
bist als den metern alter keinen plan
jetzt müssten wahrscheinlich so 60 m das
heißt keine 100
lästig aber dadurch natürlich so
dreidimensional sie ist fühlt sich
verdammt echt an
ok jetzt stehe ich wahrscheinlich genau
zur wand weil hier in die richtung
springe ich hier oben entweder büro oder
jump also entweder ich nehme jetzt sein
oder ich spring ich schon so okay jetzt
nehme ich mir das sei okay ich höre wie
das fest gemacht wird und jetzt springe
ich hörte gott all die studenten und
meine beine sind halte das ist um hier
nochmal meine bei 65 watt liegt so bei
sebastian startet das ganze jetzt auch
noch meint so etwas denn bis jetzt
angekommen an punkt erstmals sagst du
dazu fühlt sich echt an oder aber du
willst jetzt springen ohne das sei dass
sie gerade gesagt okay das ist jetzt
passiert
ich bin ins wasser gefallen und auf
einmal so minecraft pocket edition glück
bin ich also auf gras so jetzt aber
angesichts über gras gestellter termin
so und wasser einfach gehasst hat ihr
zuletzt leute wingsuit also fliegen
rebecca dax nur kurz denn die welt
schaue ich einfach mal so an button okay
und es geht los
das will ich ich gehe eben den typen
rein
omega ist dass ich fliegen also durch
die berge warten
habe lieferten
wie selbstlos ist ein nein und
jugendkultur und halter
orientierungsverlust incoming händler
sind häuser das muss jetzt langsam
gelandet im langen landet man im
bodysuit kein plan ist es halt so eine
abrupte animation gesorgt
ja klar gesagt okay jetzt bin ich eher
papiere mussten muss mit dem blick
steuern sozusagen durch die balance sich
mal auf ja okay das wäre tatsächlich die
band auch in ihre richtung
ist in die wand gefilmt mit absicht so
weit ich würde sagen das war's dann auch
schon wieder vom heutigen video wir
haben drei kleine die ahs ausgetestet
ich fand es kraft also dafür dass man
dafür nur das handy und die dating
braucht es ist schon echt ne krasse
erfahrung fandet ihr das kur- und wollt
ihr dass wir das kein plan war irgendwie
mit besonderen geschwindigkeiten oder
irgendwelchen anderen vor bienen machen
so also jetzt nicht höhenangst weil das
ging so ein bisschen auf höllenangst
europa kurz wer von uns beiden hat es am
meisten angst wer meisten affen
geräusche gemacht ich glaube ein zweiter
nicht oder können über diese gesicht
widerstehen kann die höhe dank sie bei
diesem sicherstellen dass auf jeden fall
bis zum nächsten mal